at some point i want to speak to ken
wilbur perhaps in a few months when i'm
strong enough to
and i know that ken wilbur and you have
agreements and disagreements and i'm
unsure of his model but can you tell me
where you both agree and disagree
like compare and
contrast uh
it's gonna be very hard for me to say
that because i haven't been following
his latest things you know and i was
following you or sometimes
but it's it's not a agreement this
agreement
i remember at one time there was some
disagreement some years ago
when
i was
putting out in some of my books
that as a
young children
we were in touch with our spiritual
nature
and he disagreed with that he thought no
children are like monsters they're not
in touch with the spiritual nature
and i said you know
they can be monsters but also they can
be beautiful and wonderful and joyful
and innocent and all of that and these
are spiritual qualities that was you
know this agreement we had at that time
and
i don't know at the present time i mean
he he is more
of a
philosopher of a systematizer of
of you know
of ways of experience and knowing and
life and all of that and
he's much more that way than i i am and
i'm not engaged in things in the same
way he is i think ken will agree with me
that self-reflection the stage
development of humanity and there is
other stages like uh immediate knowing
it sounds to me from what you said
earlier about the human actually i don't
know if this is from a talk i believe
this is from a talk about humans
infinite potential and that we're at a
privileged place as humans because of
our ability to self-reflect and who else
would know god if there were no humans
let's assume that there are no other
highly intelligent living creatures and
so on but that statement seems to agree
with what ken said the reason is that if
we go back to childhood we have less
self-reflective capabilities some people
may say much like you had the
disagreement that children can be closer
to god in some ways but then if we take
that further the less reflective
cognitive capabilities that we have the
more we're like the worms and the
beetles and so on so the fact that we
would say or the fact that you said in
the
human infinite potential conference or
talk that we're at a privileged place
seems to to me to indicate that actually
yes we're somehow somewhere
higher on the spiritual development
scale than children so that's why i was
saying that it sounds to me like you
actually agree with ken from what i
understood of your lessons in that other
lecture am i understanding that
incorrectly
but but you're you're putting two things
together that
i don't do
which are you talking about
self-reflective capacity
which is true it's a development that
human human being had and we don't have
it as little babies we don't have
self-reflection
however when you are in a realized place
the most realized
condition is not self-reflective
does not reflect on itself
because when it reflects itself there's
nothing there
it
can only look forward
but the point i want to say is that when
i say children are in touch with
spirituality i don't mean they're
self-reflective i mean they're being
when when they're happy they are really
happy
you see the happiness is pure
and sometimes they're happy for no
reason they're just gurgling
and for me that is a spiritual quality
they might not know it they might not
know they're happy
they know self-reflection
self-reflection is actually is a good
human quality it's necessary human
quality but at the same time it is the
beginning of ego
without self-reflection we won't have
ego
you see
and self-reflection
is
is important for spiritual practices in
general or even for inquiry the way i do
it we do need to have self-reflection
but
service is one capacity that
consciousness has but
but consciousness also can know itself
without self-reflection
can know itself by being that's that
that the english word noses comes from
you know on wazes and the way the greeks
say it is that i know myself by being
myself i'm not reflecting
it's like i'm in in expanse a medium of
consciousness
and this medium aware of itself on all
points of itself
and it is this medium is speaking to you
so it doesn't need to reflect on itself
it sees through itself
it's a the whole medium is
is not just within my body is outside of
my body too
so that's not self-reflection that is
known by being
which is the the true spiritual capacity
that people need to
develop
to
have a realization and that is actually
what those who are trying to
refer to by talk about taste because
taste is more intimate than seeing
okay something it's it's it's you know
inside or touch
or or touch is you have you have to
touch it mean you're really immediate
you're more
direct and the same thing with taste is
even more immediate it's inside you
you say while seeing is over there you
see
so immediacy
is a very important part of spiritual
all spiritual
experiences
there's no immediacy of experience which
means no it's beyond self-reflection it
is not a spiritual experience yet